Here's the answer. So here's the provided code for MainDish. It has an init
method and a str method. What we want to do with appetizer is almost the same
thing. So let's start by cutting and pasting that code. So here's the code from
the MainDish init and we'll cut and paste that into the appetizer. And now we
need to account for one little difference which instead of having sides, the
appetizer has a number of people that it serves. We also need to implement the
str method for the MainDish. We're printing out the name as str if it's
vegetarian or not. The description if it has one and the price. And you'll
notice I'm using conditional expressions here which is something you might not
of seen before. We haven't introduced it yet in this class. This is similar to
an if statement except in this case it's an expression. That means it produces a
value so we can use it in an assignment in this case giving a value to default
parameter. And what it means is, if the value of the if test is true, the value
of expression is what we put before the if. Otherwise it's what we put after the
else. So in this case we'll get the star if self dot vegetarian is true.
Otherwise we'll get nothing. This is what we did to implement str for the
MainDish. For the str function we want to do exactly the same thing for
appetizer as we did for MainDish, so we can cut and paste this code.